black holes can destroy everything but
can they be destroyed what happens if we
push physics to the absolute limit maybe
even breaking it and the universe in the
process let's create a tiny black hole
about the mass of our moon in the
courtskazak labs and try to rip it apart
experiment one
new kit
big booms break things so to set the
mood let's explode the world's entire
nuclear Arsenal around our black hole
boom
black holes swallow whatever crosses
their Event Horizon matter and energy
and since E equals MC squared all the
energy that enters a black hole
increases its mass the mass of a black
hole is proportional to its size so as
we nuke our tiny black hole it just gets
bigger and more massive
experiment two
antimatter
and antimatter annihilate each other
what will happen if we throw a moon's
massive antimatter at it unfortunately
when an object enters a black hole the
black hole will completely delete its
past identity whether it's made of
matter or of antimatter
black holes only care about gravity
which only depends on the total mass
energy of an object and the mass of a
particle is the same as its
corresponding anti-particle so throwing
an anti-moon has the same effect as
throwing a moon the black hole just gets
more massive
this deleting ability of black holes is
pretty interesting it means that despite
their size and power black holes are in
a way similar to Elementary particles
an elementary particle like an electron
is an extremely simple object fully
specified by just three numbers it's
Mass Spin and charge and amazingly the
same is true for black holes they have a
mess they can rotate and carry an
electric charge
once a black hole forms it doesn't
matter if it comes from a collapsed star
an anti-star or a banana it will always
be fully described by those three
numbers nothing else
but if a black hole is basically a weird
particle could we destroy it with an
anti-black hole
Experiment three
how exciting a particle has the same
mass as its corresponding antibarticle
but opposite charge
since a black hole has mass and electric
charge its corresponding anti-black hole
should have the same mass and opposite
electric charge what if we make them
collide
sadly the charge will just add up and
cancel out
so after the Collision we'll just get a
new black hole twice as massive with no
charge
okay we need to think bigger and stretch
physics harder
experiment four destroy the Event
Horizon
it's true that a black hole can carry
spill and charge but even for these
crazy objects there are limits if the
spin or the charge of a black hole
becomes too large something really weird
will happen The Event Horizon will
dissolve
in a simplified way we think of black
holes as hiding a singularity inside an
infinitely compressed Mass with such
strong gravity that absolutely nothing
can escape from its surroundings not
even light this is why a black hole
looks like a black sphere of nothingness
The Event Horizon is the outer edge of
this ultimate prism cross it and you'll
never be able to come back but when a
black hole rotates it works a bit like a
spinning washing machine it's as if the
rotation wants to repel nearby objects
and push them out of the black hole
which doesn't happen because its gravity
is so strong but if the rotation gets
too fast this effect will win and the
Event Horizon will disappear nearby
objects won't be imprisoned forever
anymore the same thing happens with the
electric charge make it too large and
our Ironclad jail will break open if we
manage to destroy the Event Horizon The
Singularity would still be there and
objects would still naturally fall
towards it if you hit it you would still
die horribly and quickly
but the vicinity of the singularity
won't be an inescapable prison anymore
you could get as close as you want and
come back
this should count as destroying the
black hole
can we do it
experiment 5 overfeeding
all we have to do is to overcharge or
over spin the black hole we could do
this by throwing objects with a small
mass and a lot of charge or angular
momentum so that the charge or spin
increases faster than the mass we have
to overfeed the black hole until it
reaches the point where it breaks open
however whether you can actually do this
is the subject of passionate argument
among physicists think of a Charged
black hole equal charges repel each
other and the more of the same charges
you squish together the more they push
back so let's say that we have a
negatively charged black hole and we
want to overfeed it with electrons for
example whose charge is far larger than
its mass
the electrons will feel an electrostatic
repulsion and the war electrons we throw
the larger the negative charge of the
black hole will be and the stronger the
repulsion but once we reach the upper
limit the electrostatic repulsion will
be so strong that it won't allow any
more electrons to come in at this point
the black hole will refuse to be over
fat with the spin it's similar once the
black hole reaches its upper limit it
won't gobble more spin but some
scientists have discovered what looks
like a loophole if an instant before the
black hole reaches the limit we throw
the right amount of matter in in just
the right way it looks like we could
actually overfeed it
most scientists are skeptical but let's
give it a try anyway
the end
breaking physics
there is a catch though the Event
Horizon of a black hole hides The
Singularity so destroying the Horizon
would leave us with a naked Singularity
one that is not hidden by an event
horizon and this poses a problem it
could mean the end of physics as we know
it there's a big dirty secret about
black holes contrary to widespread
belief The Singularity of a black hole
is not really at its Center no it's in
the future of whatever crosses the
Horizon black holes warp the universe so
drastically that at the Event Horizon
space and time switch their roles once
you cross it Falling Towards the center
means going towards the future that's
why you can't escape
stopping your fall and turning back
would be just as impossible as stopping
time and traveling to the Past
so the singularity is actually in your
future not in front of you and just like
you can't see your own future you won't
see the singularity until you hit it but
you also can't hit something that's in
your future any sort of experience it
like you'll experience your next
birthday when it happens
singularities that are in the future are
not a problem because we can't see them
or interact with them but a naked
Singularity would be in front of us for
all of us to see what would we see well
the whole point is that it's impossible
to know
a singularity is a region of infinite
gravity and gravity is the bending of
space-time at a singularity the bending
is so radical that the fabric of
space-time is literally broken
space and time don't exist anymore this
means that you can't predict anything
since predicting means making a forecast
about where and when something will
happen
but where and when have lost their
meaning
so we have an unpredictable thing with
infinite gravity and therefore infinite
energy this means that anything could
come out of it for no reason for a pile
of bananas to Lost socks or a solar
system predictability causality and
physics as we know it would break down
we think that singularities should exist
in nature because we can prove that
under very general conditions
gravitational collapse leads to the
formation of singularities
however scientists think that nature
forbids the formation of naked
singularities something enforces the
creation of an event horizon around them
to prevent their Insanity from infecting
the rest of the universe without event
Horizons physics may not make sense at
all so although black holes have been
portrayed as the ultimate Monsters of
the universe they may actually be the
heroes that keep us safe from The
Madness of singularities so if we do
destroy the Horizon we might destroy the
fundamental rules of the universe you
know what let's not do that
conclusion
the safe option
as far as we know there's just one safe
method to destroy a black hole wait
all black holes amid tiny particles a
phenomenon called Hawking radiation this
process causes them to slowly lose Mass
until they eventually evaporate leaving
behind no Horizon and no naked
singularity the time it takes for a
black hole to completely evaporate
depends on its mass
for our mini black hole the size of a
spec of dust it will be about 10 to the
power of 44 years 10 billion trillion
trillion times the present age of the
universe so is it possible to destroy a
black hole yes we just have to wait
but you don't have to wait that long
there are plenty of fascinating things
to explore right here on this planet
right now if you have the knowledge to
understand them to help you with that
we've created a series of lessons to
take your scientific knowledge to the
next level made in collaboration with
our friends at brilliant.org these
lessons give you a deeper understanding
of the topics from our most popular
videos from rabies and mammalian
metabolism to climate science and
supernovas there's even a lesson on
black holes where you can delve into the
fundamental principles behind their
behavior and life cycle brilliant is the
best way to master key Concepts in
everything from maths and science to
computer science and Beyond just set
your goal and Brilliant designs the
perfect path and equips you with the
right tools to reach it brilliant has
thousands of lessons to explore and each
one is interactive like a one-on-one
version of a kotskazard video their
latest course exploring data visually
will teach you everything you need and
nothing you don't to start your journey
in data science no coding skills
required you'll analyze real data set
like one about Starbucks and learn the
skills to draw insights for yourself in
a world overflowing with information
data skills are becoming essential in
virtually every field brilliant is the
perfect place to start learning them to
get Hands-On with Cutz art lessons and
explore everything brilliant has to
offer you can start your free 30-day
trial by signing up at brilliant.org
nutshell there's even an extra perk for
courtskazark viewers the first 200
people to use the link get 20 off an
annual membership once their trial ends
we love seeing how the gears interlock
with our research brilliant gives you
the tools to understand how everything
fits together
[Music]
thank you